We all love Margot Robbie.
I have like a boy-girl crush on Margot Robbie. I love her.
She would turn you straight.
(audience laughs)
As close as I can get, she could do it.
I loved her in "The Wolf of Wall Street," "Bombshell,"
"I, Tonya."
Dude, Harley Quinn!
Harley Quinn! Hello?
Every girl and boy's fantasy.
Yes.
Well, now she and actor, Sebastian Stan,
wanna work together again.
You'll remember, they met on "I, Tonya."
He played Jeff Gillooly who was Tonya's husband.
That's right.
Uh-huh.
And now UPROXX reports their next dream project
is a '90s style classic rom-com.
Do we have anyone here
who knows anything about that? (chuckles)
She does.
(audience laughs)
Apparently, they love them just like we all do.
And Sebastian says he's seen "Notting Hill,"
which is one of the best ever.
Oh.
I know.
It's medicine.
He says he's seen it so many freaking times
'cause it's his ultimate plane movie.
Do you watch rom-coms on planes? What do you watch?
I watch rom-coms all the time.
Oh, you do?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, what's the best one that you're not in.
'Cause I would say the best ones ever
are the ones that you're in.
Oh, my God.
That's so nice of you.
(audience laughs)
There are so many wonderful offerings out there.
Yeah!
(audience applauds)
I'm not being nice. I'm telling the...
Hello? I'm telling the truth.
Oh, and this is where my mom sends me a text.
She's like, "Stop rejecting people's compliments.
You're so gracious to other people.
Let it soak in."
Okay, Mom, that one's for you.
Thank you, Ross.
(Ross laughs)
Good, you're welcome.
Thank you. I appreciate that very much.
You're welcome.
I just re-watched "Knocked Up," and-
Oh, yeah.
Which is just, ugh, Judd Apatow came on the show,
and I'm literally going through his whole catalog right now.
Funny enough, I love the movie, "The Break-Up."
And I was watching it the other night,
and I was like, oh, I can't handle this right now.
Oh, really?
Uh-uh, like I just, I remember when I got a divorce,
I couldn't watch "The Handmaid's Tale."
And then five years later, I was like, "Bring it on."
Yeah.
(audience applauds)
You know? You just have to be like in the right mood.
But I love that movie.
I just love...
We all like rom-coms.
There's a reason the genre works,
and I would go see Margot Robbie and Sebastian Stan any day.
His role that he did as Tommy Lee...
Did anyone watch "Pam & Tommy?"
Oh, my gosh.
(audience applauds)
He did something that's so hard to do in acting,
which is to keep pushing you to the edge,
and show your flaws, and almost be unlikable,
but then pull you back in time and time again
and be like, those are just his flaws.
I'm on the ride with him. I'm there.
And that's not an easy art to do.
And then she is everything.
So yes, yes, yes, yes.
Them in anything.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Especially a rom-com.
All right, next up, we've got a cleaning debate
for the ages.
Ooh.
Oh.
(audience laughs)
(Drew panting)
(Ross laughs)
God, you thought rom-coms got me excited.
I know.
And you have "Stans for Stains" coming up
with Mayim, too.
Oh, baby, do I ever.
It's a big day for you.
(audience laughs)
God, I just started talking differently.
I was like, listen, toots,
(Ross laughs)
baby doll, I gotta thing for stains.
(Ross and audience laughing)
Okay, so this story is when cleaning the house,
when do you vacuum?
So "Southern Living" reports that the proper time
to vacuum is actually before
and after your big top-to-bottom house clean.
Many people wait to vacuum until the end,
and experts say that you should really vacuum first
and last.
The first vacuum kicks all the dust up,
and then you clean it and you get that last vacuum.
Whoa, this is wow.
Double down?
Yeah, I don't like this one bit.
I'll tell you why.
(audience laughs)
Do you know what vacuuming does? It sucks.
Literally, it sucks.
(Drew and audience laughing)
You're telling me to do it twice now?
I don't think so, Hoover.
Anyone here think that vacuuming twice is a good idea?
What's your name, by the way?
My name's Debbie.
Debbie?
Yes.
Debbie,
and you love vacuuming?
Hi.
I love vacuuming. I love cleaning.
I'm OCD. Well, what is it?
I'm a lucky guy. (laughs)
And that's your husband
(audience laughs)
who just said, "I'm a lucky guy."
(upbeat pop music)